this video is brought to you by better
help as two people proud to be in
therapy we are proud to be partnered
with these guys for the month of
November greetings citizens of the
reject Nation it's like I'm an alien
sometimes you guys are my friends he's
my friend nobody's ever getting
unfriended that's not what we do and we
also don't like the dark web but we do
hopefully like unfriended dark web cuz
that's what we're watching today sup
Greg what Su Roxy sup Greg you got
anything on the dark web I don't even
know if I really know what the dark web
is it's like illegal internet stuff but
how do I get there like is there a thing
that's www but dark web yeah anyone
could just access the dark
[Laughter]
web why don't more people use the dark
weapons all you got to do is type in it
on Google it's right there so you're
laughing but I'm still confused on
whether or not I could get there or not
I'm sure the movie will have an
exposition the movie will probably say
something to make it for people like you
to be like what's the dark web this is
the dark web I've heard of the dark web
whatever if you guys also have never
been to the dark web like this video I
guess if you've been to the dark web
like this video just like the video in
general comment subscribe all that good
stuff hit the notification uh and dark
web with
us you don't want to encourage people to
do that no I don't even know what dark
the verb there means no but if you want
to be the webest of all webs then be a
patrion that's the sexy webs they're
like web slinging webs those where all
the really cool kids go go to our
patreon for a full length Reaction watch
along where you sync up with your own
copy Greg and John cover several shows
over there exclusively with reaction
highlights talk about and watch alongs
included that's what's
up dark BR we dark web in tonight man I
want you to not look down for a second
how long do you think my intro's been uh
dear I I've stopped having anxiety about
it gotten used to when Roxy introduces
the video I will figure out what to
cut sending multiple intros to be like I
managed to cut out 30 more seconds but I
do watch every video and I see what you
cut and I like what you do I appreciate
that I like what you do too you give me
plenty to work with I have the clicker
no that's the work oh
no you guys cannot see what's happening
on the screen
right no it's TW no no
okay in three two
[Music]
one
bird there's something wrong with me man
yeah yeah what would it take for you to
unfriend me on the socials finding out
you're not actually
Jewish that would be like what a liar
that would be
trash you remember that sound if you are
old enough you remember that sound yeah
I mean it's just a Mac no that's not
what it sounds like anymore right that's
what it sounded like when on my bluec I
hope like five-year-olds aren't watching
this
video is your password just P oh now
we're trying to guess it maybe try with
exclamation
points you're going to get locked out
maybe not at this time
period
quiry what's quty I think they're just
trying anything at that Point feel the
burn big interesting kofifi okay so this
is after
Trump whoa no [__] your password can't
even just be
one oh wow the attention to detail on
this
oh away I went to college with him oh
really what's his name Colin
w
[Music]
back on the Facebook do you use Facebook
ever not really no I had to uh go to
some event and I had to say yes on it
recently that's the story of how I use
Facebook
ever okay so we're going from Nora to
Matt but is it him using the computer
because he seemed like he couldn't
remember the password for the longest
time but yeah but it was logged into
Nora so I'm assuming it's Norah's
computer because that he logged into
easily
test Maya is going to love this oh he's
trying to surprise
her crap this is
[__] good you learn all the right
words okay so there's aaya there's Nora
there's
Maddie and there's a J unless AJ is a
place no I think it's a
person there you are just remember who
has two thumbs and gives the best
massages in the
world what why isn't she speaking she's
hearing imp faired that's why he was
doing the sign language oh oh
yeah did not I got a new computer today
it's much faster than my old one oh and
she can see it that's cool
oh so cute that's neat so uh when the
app doesn't understand a word you just
you just type it in and it automatically
connects you to the ASL site and then
there's a video tutorial on how to do it
wow there's so many lags happening on
screen right now Dam she doesn't seem
happy with this I know she seems
extremely exasperated right now from
when you told me how hard it was for you
to understand me when I'm on
Skype are they just like looping her
same
look
can you can you type her screens are
kind of
off she seems so incredibly she annoyed
with him or about some situation she's
trying to vent about I don't I think
she's annoyed with him maybe that's not
what she wanted how are we going to get
into the dark web with this whatever he
downloaded must have had like bugs or
something I don't
know whenever it freezes I feel like
it's the movie I like I mean like feel
like we're have to like fix an edit well
the spinning wheel of death always is
going to make you
feel the editing on this one already
seems completely different though they
have to do something a little
stylistically different yeah updated
technology probably was easier to match
some things but it's definitely anxiety
driven the camera quality is really
good
oh no this a very odd Pace setup and
they're introducing a lot of characters
in strange
ways why is he like logged into her
stuff is it her
computer downloaded something on her end
and maybe she saw something I'm not sure
Mary Ann I'm so Nora oh good been
working waiting so long we're finally
going to meet up oh don't fall for those
oh yeah but remember he's not logged
into his own thing this is Nora writing
to writing Nora and he's seeing it who's
Nora I don't know yet I'm you again this
movie makes me be Cy I know I
know another person too I get it you're
asking all the questions I'm thinking
and I'm like but I'm sure we'll find out
eventually
putting what in
the what are you putting in your gas
thing don't put booze in
there so he doesn't know who Norah
is damn this Norah gets around maybe
it's an alter ego of Maya or
[Music]
something did you send the plane tickets
yeah it's obviously somebody is like
hooking up with a lot of people guys got
this for nari for her birthday because I
guess I'm trying to compensate hi MTV my
name is Kendra I live in Malibu I'm into
blank and I love to this one so strange
I don't understand some stuff that's
happening my name is Kendra I'm from
Malibu I'm into having on top of a pizza
my name is Kendra I'm from Malibu I'm
really into the systematic destruction
of an entire people and their way of
life this is part of their game I guess
that they do I can see the pores on on
your face that actually looks like
you're calling from the year 2018 I mean
it's a 4 30 frames a second I don't
think you're ready for this I got a new
laptop it's a refurbished laptop and it
was formerly Nora's yeah or not
refurbished he stole it I don't think
stole but maybe that's why you couldn't
figure out the password I got some
killer Bud yeah I know I heard you I
just wanted Linda to here too she's not
going to she still thinks marijuana is
illegal here damn you're going behind a
woman's back like
that is going to sound like a a nitpick
and it is it cuts to the people on their
on their singles before they start
speaking yeah and I'm like that's not
how Skype or Zoom works you have to
start talking first before it goes to
the single it keeps like pulling me
out this one feels like
more movie yeah totally and less like
I'm watching a screen recording but
we're still early so G to wait I like
that we have one of the boxes with two
people this time because at least we'll
be able to see the dynamic between the
two of them sure yeah yeah is Nora a guy
wh why do you think Facebook and Twitter
are free because you're the product they
do find very natural actors oh no
they're Gathering your data man there
are sharks swiming below you they're
just going to they're going to come in
from right up behind you when you don't
even see it coming and they're just oh
yeah explore that hard drive what's in
there cell towers GPS IP address
detection Bluetooth device
tracking your head ah huh Bear yeah a
teddy bear in a survivalist bunker with
a year supply of food guns and ammo I
want to fix this I want us to work what
happened in your relationship whatever
we just saw maybe he didn't learn how to
speak sign language fast enough yes a
someone clearly stole this laptop and he
bought B it off
[Music]
on it's like all just like a Side Story
is it a story or is a random people side
improv or something
[Music]
yeah so these are all things that I
found yeah I guess these are all the
people that this Norah person interacted
with
cameras yeah it's
all miss all different addresses oh wait
wait oh wait hold on I'm going to play
it now okay check it out I just got
these new
speakers look how just whoa you guys see
that though look at my new bombs Bam Bam
Bam why is why is our guy not mentioning
any of this to the group conversation
well he is talking to that one person on
the side should we wait for Amaya I
don't think Amaya's going to be coming
they yeah
it's my mom's ring did you ask nar's Dad
for permission and did you film it
please say you did because oh my God I
just I love the look on his face like
you brought up a sore subject I would
really love to see that that face again
it was cool when you stood up to him
that's all I'm saying it's just dude
dude I don't even know the whole
backstory but I felt uncomfortable about
that is your mom excited the Cancer's
progressed it's moved into her brain and
they have her own life support though
and they're really trying some
aggressive treatments so this just went
from yeah he to libo's darkest [__] just
progressed in there but they progressed
they have her on life support that was a
wild line I remember when I had to put
my dog down oh my God that was my least
favorite thing people would do when my
mom was sick I oh my God it's like I get
how much people love their dogs but it's
just not the same God you're so bad at
this so bad no I am so thr oh my God I
used to [__] hate
that H they're just trying to keep up
you know it's a game of tops when
someone dies in your family yeah but
everybody with the
dog no
noa's favorite sunset this
La okay this is cute as
[__]
oh answer what are you doing like I I I
know I know you're mad at me and I know
we we we've both been busy but I feel
like I know I I've been spending a lot
of time on this app but I've been doing
it why can't you just type
it that is a fair
assessment yeah so it was about
that class and you never went yet you
didn't put in the
effort maybe ignore that [__]
no no I'm just
uh yo stop getting so distracted Y what
the hell is up with it man Focus
up Amaya obviously she hung up you
deserved that times a thousand and I
don't feel like you actually did go to
the ASL class and really have it out for
this guy no I just don't think he went
what guy has ever scorned you take it
out on
him oh he's been caught no but he didn't
he bought it off Craigslist that person
he has to he has to have known it was a
stolen laptop though why cuz of all the
[__] that's on here it's like not
cleaned out of someone else's personal
stuff that's G
gone oh he doesn't have one he did steal
it oh did he actually steal it maybe
it's weird the first movie had such a
solid easy to follow like setup in the
first like 5 to 10 minutes of its
characters and the drama and what's
possibly at stake and then here it's
been like a slow reveal to understand
what's going on I'll leave it where I
found it I'll go now why would you steal
it and then bring it back it's like
structurally very different yet
stylistically super similar I think he's
going to actually bring it back and then
that person is going to like torture his
friends where are you going yeah yeah
yeah I I'll I'll explain later all right
bye then is everything
okay sometimes that going so is Norah's
like this like super hot lesbian
prostitute maybe she leaves it out for
it to get stolen on purpose to mess with
[Music]
people is an NA
I
guess what's this guy's motivation
exactly what's that his friend is like
not asking anything like why are you
asking me all these questions wait
what's going on you want to share share
your screen mate oh this is where all
went wrong all right that's that's an
overlay Network you're being bounc
around around everywhere so no one can
track you dude this is darket It's where
you find market places for bad [__]
basically like um I get it but how do
you get there the river you need certain
devices to access it I've never accessed
it looks like an old school BBS Charon
it's a Fairman of the Dead the Fairman
of Hades who carries Souls of the newly
deceased across the river stes
and so real yeah dude whose computer did
you buy there's a cyber cafe that I've
been that I've been working at noticed
this computer was sitting in the lost
and found for the last 3 or 4 weeks wait
wait hang on you stole someone's
computer because I wanted a better
computer to work on my app with and then
oh your theory might be right when when
I went on Facebook all of his stuff Auto
filled it's a fake name guys it's Charon
backwards nah he's the smart one he's
one of them and whoever they are they
must this is where they meet up to trade
I get rid of that computer and stop
sharing the screen one of them was
actually sending me private messages
earlier it was Shon 68 poor schmuck
never made it to
I hope that was not scripted I was
looking around and I found this uh this
folder right it was hidden invisible and
it's got videos 960 gig show us why are
you still on this River thing he is very
intense that one guy that's here that's
the one's on the east side
and oh they're hacking people's cameras
hackers drive through neighborhoods
trying to scoop up Wi-Fi addresses of
any unsecured or vulnerable round so
they can hackers can activate the camera
on laptops and phones and disable the
indicator lights so you wouldn't even
know that they were on damn did you open
that link in the folder the one called
account wait that that's just from a
couple of minutes ago it's crypto
currency that's $10 million guys we'll
take it it's almost 11 free money just
sitting there no no there's no such
thing as free money AJ
facts
[Laughter]
there's there has to be a way to just
take it they're trading on the dark web
via
Bitcoin ask for more type uh for
what no
no I have no idea what he's talking
about
want tration the sound effect of
whatever something went through is
hilarious a surgical procedure in which
a hole is drillen to the skull oh you do
it to
yourself oh
[__]
oh ah this Nora person's
awful oh isn't settling in a very
different way because it's praying on
something very real Sharon 68 the first
thing he wrote was that he liked the
last contribution go back to the video
folder and scroll all the way to the
bottom or filter to date created first
no Matias don't open it please no just
open why would you want to see
this oh 45 minutes yeah this is the rest
of the movie
yeah and it just never log off I just
want to keep watching wouldn't they be
able to trap track where the laptop is
that's horrible this is really
unsettling why is everyone so
quiet I think they don't know what to
say oh God oh my God they're going to
bury her alive it's really good at being
very creepy without showing much okay
now I can't I can't it lets you fill in
the rest it's really
clever yo our homeboy seems way too
curious about all this I would not be I
would I would stop what would you do
though call the cops I get rid of the
laptop yeah get rid of the laptop and
then what I would call the cops yeah get
rid of the laptop take it to the police
they need the laptop take it to the
police okay what am I going to do with
this show me the most recent one Nori
let's not forget there's got to be a
supernatural element to it because there
was the first time yeah I don't think
that means that there has to be this
time right they did have that deep the
Charon thing whatever that was wa
stop
this can't be
real set up a camera in the house to
break in and do
that see if I can see who did why is he
looking at the camera that was it right
yeah yeah yeah yeah well then he might
not have her yet oh that's why he
chooses a girl shows her to the rest of
the group and waits for someone to pay
and someone just paid we have our
address so just we can do a reverse
phone Lookout you think they going to go
after Amaya I feel they go after Amaya
but no they would know if that was her
bedroom though oh no oh
no she's not trying to get a hold of him
go to her
house Kelly someone's broken it
Kelly oh that is
creepy hey hey hold on one second damn
I'm
SOA with you right now no I mean I just
got in I think Amaya's in the shower you
possibly get it for me right now wow
I can hear you are you still can't see
you there's a lot going on I know the
editing is jarring in a weird way
sometimes it serves it and other times
it's whoa what the oh
noell oh my God
[Music]
K is he still logged into
Skype
yeah I think this entity travels via
this way what do you mean I don't feel
like it's a person really going I feel
like they travel via through the screen
in some way you don't think they found
the Amaya's
address okay I hear what you're saying
it's not NE I don't know that it's wrong
it's not my interpretation so
far and she's hearing impared you know
like it couldn't have been her messaging
cuz she was in the shower don't go in
there don't go in there don't don't go
don't stop stop stop stop
okay oh my God [__] it must it must be a
a bug or something your your computer
called mine um uh Kelly Kelly just type
it say something she brought a she
brought a guy home he's she's don't
don't no don't disconnect I'll I'll wait
for you I'll wait I'll wait for you my
God is he not going to tell why get
there call the cops do something what
this is so
weird why is he just sitting there I
this is so confusing I don't know yeah
I'm a little bit some of the choices are
a little odd please please just please
don't hurt her I'll do anything you want
me to do I will do anything I
promise a Black
Mirror yeah that's how I think he found
a
Place whoa that Distortion of the screen
is really odd
yeah so they're here to save someone's
life wait just one second can you
wait if all he really wanted was a
laptop he would have got it from the
coffee shop I don't think this I feel
like this is probably some type of
entity 100% or he was lying about it
being at the coffee shop for weeks and
he took it
dude he can see you messaging that we
called the police or what we're not
calling the police we're going to the
police okay but you need to trust us no
get the laptop go down to the police
station no I have a friend that will
meet us he knows how to deal with this
kind of situation it's not real oh my
God it's a g it's a game I I I made the
whole thing up it's a game Lex you were
you were totally on to me from the
beginning oh he can't he can't tell them
the truth right right holy [__] I guess
that means it was pretty goodas this is
not
[Laughter]
funny it's it's an alternate reality
game exactly yeah I love how he's
appreciated this
idea where'd you get those videos that
is some dark [__] yeah no I know it's
just um horror film horror films what if
we'd call the police ideally you would
you would register to play with your
your cell number so if uh by the time
you logged in you called 911 it would
hack your phone and you would get a
recording like like the bad guy your
phone wow he is a masterful liar
especially in a high situ he didn't the
laptop wasn't actually sitting there
[Music]
for now convince the m to come to you
now the story Line's much more in depth
how it builds this this this special
bond the ability to to communicate with
with someone in in a special way
that I'm really scared am I oh my
God what this is just so much or any the
way I care about you the night we met at
the bar music was was so loud and a
beautiful person wouldn't be able to
hear you anyways it's so
loud that all that noise wouldn't matter
that's what I want for us
nothing else to matter I want nothing
she seems happier her smile is a good
indication I need you to get here as as
fast as you can okay take um uh take
take the subway okay oh no man this is a
desperate isolation
situation Lex mute your m
you are louder than her all the actors
are good I just don't not really as
connected to the group dynamic I don't
really know W they are and why they are
the way they are well they seem like
better
people fair enough you know what I mean
sure I'm gonna be honest I I was totally
there but they he can see your
screen oh [__] that's who was
[Music]
messaging wow he was one scroll down
from seeing all this say if we had
decided to do something with the bad
guy's money if we' taken it then how
does that Ripple through the rest of the
story what is he thinking about with the
money oh yeah I think I think he's
trying to
[Music]
threaten
good and watch this cinematic
glitches I
they Bitcoin is the cause of all bad
things oh my God can you just do
that apparently
[Music]
yeah dude you get the computer back when
I get aaya back you get the money back
when I see on the news that Erica dun is
back home
safe
uhoh stupid mother all I want is my
laptop all I want is aaya you don't
understand you killed Kelly no I didn't
if you lay a hand on a Maya shut the and
listen the people I work with all the
other Sharon primes they monitor all
Bitcoin accounts they're going to think
I'm trying to cash
out oh great so now they're going to
hurt Amaya it did feel like a a little
bit of a a rash move what's going on
what's Happening I I I I I don't I don't
know oh my God now he's got to work with
this guy you know what I'm just I'm
going to close it no do not close it
they're going to know you're not
me are they talking to you what are they
saying oh my God they're saying they're
saying recite the code oh God just put a
bullet in our head you stupid oh my God
the voice is disappearing he's becoming
a human being if they find out that I
lost that computer they're going to kill
me they're going to kill you and they're
going to kill anyone else that might
have seen just give just give me the
code
what you killed no I didn't I just
bashed your head she'll wake up and
think it was a a robbery or something we
have no time for this they said this is
your last chance Sharon
for Sharon four type A B Y SS u s wait
they're typing in all caps should it be
in all caps just send
it why did you join your account tell
them I switch from Bitcoin to ethereum I
would said I'm switching just use his
exact words you're asking why it's a
better exchange rate I got a tip why
don't you sh this a verb if I let Erica
go they're going to lose Faith they're
going to hold me liable but you'll have
$10 million to help you figure out how
to disappear if anything goes wrong
between here and there you're both dead
he's just going to kill him anyway like
why wouldn't he just come and kill both
them he's obviously willing to kill
anybody so I found the girl from your
video she's real her name's Erica Dunn
ladies stop where did you even get the
video Live Leak yeah some someone on the
inside just must have must have leaked
it or something I don't know why would
you use that video yeah he's like ladies
cut it out stop style it back trying to
save a life right
now oh great oh we're back to the first
movie how do we get this person off does
anyone know how we get this person
off wait what's going on come on Maas oh
[__] the dark WB people have hacked them
the link do not click the link you hear
me guys we didn't click the link but the
video is playing anyway oh no what the
where's Lexi senior year that's December
dash at mcc's puia oh that's so scary
that is scary
what I mean
they yeah they're revealing how they got
them yeah wait guys where's Lex oh I
know she's probably still getting
theing
Le they're College friends okay
where is she okay I
am is she in on this masas what's going
on
oh oh
no is that Lex must be oh you guys are
all dead like a th% how close how close
are you to the subway can you stay on
the call just just keep your keep your
phone in your pocket or or or whatever
just just just stay on
okay yeah who are you calling I'm
calling Lex don't listen to me for a
second right no no more calls all right
we just uh you can you can leave your
phones on feel this person stressing
yeah yeah yeah hang up the phone I'm not
I'm going to call the police right now
calm down give me one more second please
me one more depending is real the whole
thing is real oh my God he can hear and
see everything all right he he he found
a my apartment she was the first person
I called so he must have been able to
track her somehow or I don't know I
don't trust to have one guy I feel like
it's a big Ploy what okay the guy who's
like who took the money from the Charing
guy the laptop own how do you know he's
not listening now because of because of
Facebook Chat the green light it goes
off when she loses connection that's why
I told her to take the subway what about
the other people when she went
underground then I could tell you guys
what was happening all right look
there's there's no service in the
station oh they're hacking his the
computer via through there okay it might
have happened when when he didn't have
connection
or oh [__] no he's got a girlfriend or
wife right mom was upstairs I think I
don't know that he said he didn't want
to smoke in front of Jesus Christ mom
what you
mom Maddie you are so dead what
the
please oh my God
couldn't he have send a text message no
he's his phone is not connected though
he said he was watching him though they
have cameras at his place so uh who
wants to go
first oh my God I'll go they're being so
awkward be be better actors she
especially like I don't want to put up
with this [__] right now my gym
teacher got fired for adding blank to
the obstacle course too much cocaine
velcro
depression I like
velcro thought depression was pretty
good all right I'll
go is you action comedy Jackie Chan must
fend off ninjas while Al hey uh nari
we're trying to play uh a a horse with
no legs her boyfriend show up going
going around punching people
and where's Lexi oh they didn't see
where Lexi went wow yeah give me access
of laptop assist preferences users in
groups add user Make sure you give me
administrative access you guys my friend
on the force is coming over here no and
you and your mom get the hell out of
your house you're the only one who might
not be safe Damon's in London they can't
get to him and nar's got a friend on the
floor so so the cops are already on
their way I'm being in London doesn't
feel like
a oh no um did it break down or did they
do something to hack the subway Serena
nari Serena
guys hello all cuz you stole a laptop
dude Nar skipping this round how much
longer how much longer for where' the
subway break down let me let me just let
me ask
Purge go on where did you break down in
my bedroom uh Western Boulevard that is
in Hollywood what's going on with nari
bathroom she's not feeling well it might
be a
while what was that it's the
cop the way of AJ so sick and tired of
all you sheep will not they're going to
show how they're going to find him a
storehouse of assault weapons and
explosives weapons and explosives
weapons oh this poor guy with the
conspiracy theory Channel having this
all happened to
him oh how would have taunt in maneuver
the nature of your emergency I am sick
and tired of all the corruption sir is
this a real emergency I'm going to pack
up all my assault weapons and explosives
go downtown to the mall and oh how cruel
Jeff Co is a family
name wow that was just so recent they
made that call 10 minutes ago AJ you
need
to we have no
I just get just get on the ground oh my
God they're going to kill him oh oh wow
what a cruel
maneuver right here what's on the
screen Illuminati they're into his
computer oh they're they're lo oh my God
they're putting things on his computer
they're downloading stuff they're
downloading oh my God they're going to
download gunfire or
something they're going to play it
well oh my God oh my God oh my God I
knew it no no stay no aent oh they're so
taunting oh that's so mean
[Music]
no that was horrible to watch that was
the worst one yet oh my god wow they're
like going up against a secret
society yeah they
[Music]
know as soon as the train reaches the
station no nari is on her way there no
oh my God I can get there faster I'm
going to go
now oh they're all getting
a the great words John Humphrey ug the
other people didn't deserve it I don't
think this really matters on the
deserved no the other people more
deserved it but it was still like these
people are good Oh you mean the movie
they me the people the here no you want
to not tell them tonight or or no it's
perfect because this way Dam gets to be
there for the news AJ will be fine he's
a big boy um quickly do they scan their
[__] you would love that or with a boom
box just John
style we can't hear him but he's trying
to talk they're only daughter
so my mom no no she has what are they
playing this back I think they're about
to go find her at the hospital this
about going to be about her mom and we
can bring the paperwork and in I see you
she'll be our witness yes yes you're
going to say where she is I don't want
you to have to choose between me and
them it's not fair they're going to make
her choose between her and her mom or
something y oh she's going to get pushed
in front of the train TR be her or her
mom I think it's going to be a choice
yep there's her Mom they're going to try
to kill one of them and make her choose
which one's to
save yeah who would you choose her mom
is going to die yeah so you choose your
girlfriend it's horrible but that's what
you do
no no no no no I will do anything stop
this right now I will do
anything oh man so in control I love how
there's a personality to it I think
they're going to kill both
regardless no
no I won't demonstrating as much
strength as you think you
are no oh that is cruel
[Music]
wow oh man that guy behind her is just
going to turn around and push
her
Dam yikes would the guy also die looked
like
that he's there Serena Serena get out of
there right now Serena get out of there
right now oh my God yeah see the way
they travel though feels like not real I
think there's just a lot of
them
listen to me I want you to listen to me
whoever I'm talking to right now
nobody's listening to you honey the guy
who lost it he's he's on the subway
train with her he's wearing a gray
hoodie this is all his fault okay she
has nothing nothing to do with it man
what an unflattering shot I had seen
that in the
theaters her whole performance this
whole time
she
yeah speak in sign language that they
don't understand I'm sure they could
interpret it oh my God no they're not
going to be able to he needs to just
talk to
her
slow I really got to learn sign language
you going to get him man yeah I am well
just make sure you leave the computer
because I got to keep downloading the
video files okay do you think he's in on
it
how great would that be you're there
aren't
you bait laptop guess what I've been
recording you should have dealt with
mathas who was going to give the
computer back but that is not what I'm
going to do this is everywhere that
computer has been this is going to lead
them to Erica and every single go you
took you're going to come right into his
place right
now
Photoshop oh they're going to photoshop
his face on
it
they are so evil I can't get over it man
oh my God how
cruel they just have some like weird
ability they're going to plant things
there they're going to plant the girl
it's Erica
done do they have some like weird
software enabler on their their bodies
and their cells that can he didn't lose
the laptop Shon 4 he left it there
deliberately he wanted it to be found
they all wanted it to be found it was a
lure yeah dependent on him it was a lie
they're setting us up we did everything
they wanted us to do we moved the money
we copied the videos they're going to
make it look like it was us the whole
time oh my God was a my head on it I'm
almost I'm a second away I'm a second
away no way inside where inside where
you're home but we had our first kiss
Amaya
ah Maya I I I didn't I didn't send you
anything oh this poor
woman is papaya going to
help no oh my God they think it's him
damn why' they choose these guys to pin
it on to cuz they saw him at the shop
every day I don't know this is such an
icky ass experience cuz they knew Damon
was a tech guy so that he have the
capability when they looked into it oh
my God they're at his home
yeah oh the confession
letter
holy [__] how
clever cuz remember he downloaded it
all what a proper setup oh she's in the
room that with the canister initially
remember
yeah but how do they travel like this
there's a lot of
them is game night they can sneak up
though game night game night oh she's
here a bear too
yeah oh this is their game night oh my
God this is their effing game
night wow how many people
that's what I'm saying there's a lot of
them is it the girl from the first movie
no it's er done why would it be the girl
from the first
movie the drill yeah oh my
God don't pull it out
oh the horror of
that let him die it's going to be die
and then it's going to cut yeah so many
now
yeah see like how does he not hear a fan
coming his
[Music]
way remember they have to show their
faces every
time that's the like insurance policy
[Music]
yeah women two game night wow that was
wild cops in on it that was
wild well it's interesting there's not a
supernatural element this time I didn't
think there was going to be cuz dark web
I felt like that makes it more
susceptible to have a supernatural
element you know things happen to a lot
of people in this they do man honestly I
think that there if any of them had made
it out alive there' only be one solution
for them oh what was that and they need
to talk to somebody talk to what like a
therapist clearly I need to talk to a
therapist you need talk everybody needs
to oh you know what that actually gives
me an idea if you just step out of the
video for a second I could talk to the
audience I think it's really important
to play them and they come right back
and we'll act like we never even lost
time I got
you today's episode is sponsored by
better help I know that we often joke
around here quite a bit on the channel
but I wanted to speak a little bit more
sincere during this specific sponsor and
I'll start off by saying this that you
know with any sponsor they usually give
like suggested things to consider uh
when talking about the sponsor and one
of their suggested things was was a
question that they had there that went
along the lines of like have you ever
laid awake with your thoughts racing
wishing for a moment of silence and I
thought to myself well yeah that's my
secret cap I got know that feeling way
too well and it's in those Quiet Moments
where you're battling your own mind
where you are seeking Clarity the most
and you may have heard me talk about
this on the channel before the better
part of a decade now therapy has
undoubtedly been one of my main anchors
before there was ever the real rejects I
was diagnosed with PTSD type 2 bipolar
and ADHD so uh needless to say I needed
some therapy and through its guidance
I've Unearthed deeper layers of myself
cultivate to richer relationships and
just have a more profound understanding
of my emotions and one of the best parts
about it is it's giving me a space where
it's free from judgment where I found my
voice and learned the art of truly
listening not just to others but also to
myself I've talked a little bit about
how this year I've focused a lot more on
my physical health and hit in the gym a
little bit more often and in all
sincerity I do view therapy as like the
a gym for your mental health a place
where you can really nurture your mental
wellbeing and it is an experience that
has been quite transformative so much to
the point that you know I would say at
least half of the people that you see
that come here on the channel are in
therapy as a matter of fact I know one
of them their therapist is with better
help I often joke that like I've been in
therapy since it was underground why I
joke like that is because I I see now in
the past few years a lot more people
have been going to therapy which is
fantastic I'd love seeing that so I will
say that if in your heart if you have
been seeking therapy or contemplating
going to therapy I highly encourage you
I urge you to consider better help
before I ever saw some ad for better
help I had heard other people who had
been with better help and had really
given strong in-person testimonies to me
their online platform is crafted with
care keeping your comfort in mind
starting it as simple as answering a few
questions and really important to
remember it's a journey and I really
love this because I've had uh at least
like three therapists in my life so if
you ever feel the need to change your
therapist better help understands and
allows it without any fuss trust me
that's a massive benefit so for a
journey of Discovery and mental
well-being turn to betterhelp embark on
this heartfelt Joy at betterhelp.com
that's
hp.com Rejects and embrace 10% off your
first month genuinely thank you to
better help for sponsoring this video
it's weird I thought the first one dealt
with a
more serious probably a more
relatable subject matter for more people
and
yet and and something that was a much
more sensitive subject I think the first
one the just like the the premise of
like go kill yourself on the internet go
un alive yourself yeah yeah and the
cyber bullying and all that like the
like dark web activities are very much
real um however I think like that one's
a little bit
more yeah I would say I would say like a
little bit more like you you can connect
with that or empathize with that more
because we're a little bit more privy to
that last name was written house yet I
thought the first one I walked away with
like that was fun and this one I was
like this is a really uncomfortable
experience well the first one was
targeted right we know why by the end
why them this one it's just
like you know things happen and wrong
place wrong time and they pinned it on
them for funsies just scary creepy true
really creepy oh such a bummer for
Rebecca written
house
why because of Kyle Written House oh
really I don't know I I don't think
they're related I'm just saying I
wouldn't want the last name of anyway
you should see my friend Steven dmer
yeah I think that would be a that would
really be a balber yeah um or George
Hitler you met him is that real yeah he
my neighbor May serious no oh I could
have kept this big going for a while
that would be crazy um yeah I would have
changed my last name if my last name was
Hiller yeah I would hope so I I think
I'd be like don't have a sense of Pride
my friend this was really
creepy they did a good job it was
different it felt like different editors
because we did spend a lot more time
away from our computers in this one yeah
you know like there with the flashing
different videos and stuff we did do
that last time too though and I like the
dynamic of having two people in
one yeah but the the fact that none of
them had like wronged each other and it
wasn't
like as much about that and more was
just like we need to pin this on you
guys
creepy yeah I think structurally I I
feel like I could have used a tiny bit
more like in the first like 20 to 30
minutes
I found myself just trying to play a
little bit of keep up with what's going
on wait what did it just say the story
name are are all fictitious oh
fictitious
yeah okay what do you think it said I
don't know usually at the end I find at
the end of things I didn't know if it
was saying like based on a true story oh
yeah yeah um I think I think in like the
first 20 to 30 minutes structurally
there
were I could have used a little bit more
kind of a personal investment in in
these in the people first it like CU
there comes that point where he stops to
break away he's like yeah there's
something happening on my computer I
bought this computer off Craigslist
there's this thing happening and that's
at like the 30 minute Mark in the movie
right and I I did wish that we kind of
got clued in a little bit more to the
personal Dynamics between them other
than just sort of the surface level
stuff yeah but I I I definitely hear you
but I do think it's interesting that you
were asking significantly more questions
than normal and I think that was maybe
the purpose like the first one was much
more straightforward this one wanted you
to Fig have it unfold as it's unfolding
for them kind of I agree I I I I do
think that there was a a world where I
could have had because I was more just
like I was more focused on like
understanding the information and plot
and less so having like an an emotional
investment and that but that emotional
investment eventually did come around at
like the halfway point in this movie um
and I think the world of it was very
well done at first I was sort of getting
the impression that they had stylistic
choices first that they wanted to toy
with and then they were building they
like the filmmakers yeah and then they
built a narrative around that versus the
reverse you know I felt like there were
first leading a little bit to surface
with like its gimmick and what other
neat way can we do it but then
eventually I really started to feel like
the story at of it all and the the
intensity of it unfolding like I I think
like as it escalated I love I really
love the escalation of it like when the
dark web Circle people came in and just
started hacking their Skype chat I'm
like that is really scary I thought that
was genuinely a really scary and felt
more
that that felt more like uh real and
tangible like the the last
movie you just start going like it's got
to be Supernatural like you just feel
that it's probably Supernatural and then
this one I think that's why it's a
little bit more icky because even though
the subject matter in the first one is a
lot more sensitive this this feels like
there's a world here where [__] like
this actually goes down it kind of
reminded me of purge like at times with
like the the
and like just being their game night as
we were getting towards the end it kind
of did feel like that do you think that
you would Black Mirror meets Purge yeah
yeah do you think that you would have
thought that this was cuz the whole time
you were like there's got to be
Supernatural angle if it wasn't for
being a sequel would you have thought
that no I would have thought okay so it
was only because like usually in a
franchise they kind of stick to that
same level of Supernatural whatever that
level is yeah I mean there there are
times here where it becomes a little
bit I don't know honestly the thing is I
really really don't know there are
things that register to me
as SciFi I would say like like the
Glitchy cameras every time they walk in
the room kind of thing I just think that
there was something in their pocket or
whatever yeah there was something there
that would happen in on the text
messages when it would it would delete
it would always have the like this
jittery thing and whenever they talk to
the chat the the charin there's always
like thud sound effect whenever they
enter and I couldn't tell if that was a
filmmaker choice or if that's what our
character was also hearing on his end of
the screen there were there were things
about it where it would feel sci-fi to
me which would make me think of like a
black mirrror um and that's why I would
sometimes be led into thinking that
there's probably something Supernatural
also happening however the short answer
to your question is yeah I definitely I
definitely found myself going down the
rabbit hole of thinking there's some
ghostly entity element more because of
the first movie did you like this even
in the same category as the first movie
like I I think that you like this one
less but did you like it close to as
much or for you was the first movie just
a significantly better
movie I think the first movie is a
tighter film I think the first movie is
a stronger film um but there are
elements here
that I really did love like the the last
half of this movie I loved I really did
I this took a long time to get there it
took me I was really thinking like I'm
not sure I'm going to like this movie
cuz like I wasn't giving a [__] about
anybody whereas in the first movie we
did like you and I were both going back
and forth like wow these people feel so
even though even though they're all
[__] like even though as the movie
kept going you find out they're all
dicks you they felt so real and you felt
like you really got to know them um so
early on that I was more attached to it
and and the Mystery around it I thought
was more alluring right off the bat and
there was also a personal tie-in to the
thing they were enveloped in and to me
this the sensibilities of that choice
and dynamic just make for a more
engaging story for me personally but the
subject matter of this and uh the
cleverness of this and also the the fact
that it feels
real really spoke a lot of volumes to me
and made it icky like I I I think you
and I are having like different
responses when people were kind of
getting killed as I was going like this
is so evil but I was having fun with how
evil it was because it was just like
damn watching hang and I was like can't
believe they're showing us this and
you're like I was like yeah this is
[__] up man like this is like this is
so cruel and like they're so clever and
uh yeah that was I thought that was
really me what did you what did you
think though did you prefer it the I
think that you know the first one
because we really went in super blind we
were it was like threw us into this
world which is unlike anything I've ever
seen in a movie before so it's unfair
because I'm biased that the first one to
me is just like incredible I just
thought it was so wonderful I think this
is the best version of a sequel they
could possibly make though that's good
that's a good point because the first
one if we just saw it again but with
different friends and the same kind of
hacker who's like out for vengeance or
whatever it they did that version
already and they did the best version of
that movie so I feel like they they was
smart by making it dark web because they
went after people who didn't necessarily
deserve it they had this like it was
kind of this larger world the reason it
reminded me of purge is in the first
Purge that I watched It's just in the
house and in the second Purge we go out
into the world and this kind of felt
like that in the first unfriended were
just it's an isolated story but in the
second one we see this is game night for
tens of thousands of people voting on
who lives and dies and how uh and it
just felt like a more evil society and
world with the chirons and I think that
that was really clever and different and
the best sequel we could get from this
even though it wasn't as Innovative as
the first one because I hadn't seen a
movie like that yeah to me it really
just comes down to the the the the the
in I keep bringing it up the investment
of the of the core cast of characters
and it's not it's not solely like just
to comp because like I said like I agree
like th% with everything you're saying
you bring up like really really strong
points and especially for like what
would you do in a sequel yeah
congratulations Ro lectra Point let's
go it is a question I'm
smart know I
win it's it's that
and it's not it's not I'm really I'm
just using this as a way to not not to
compare just to use as an
example
of I guess it is a comparison
ultimately the I really felt like in the
first movie that Ensemble were real
friends who've known each other a long
time you know and then here I felt
Cinema I felt actors uh cast while they
were all great actors I thought everyone
did a a really great job it never quite
reached the level of I believe the
history of of them it still felt like I
was still aware I was watching actors I
hear you we did spend less time also
developing that history you know I think
we were an hour and 20 minutes in when
you were like oh they went to college
together yeah you know and it's like
okay so in the last one we obviously
knew who like as the secrets are being
revealed but like this person hooked up
with this person this person doesn't
like this person like as somebody was
brought in the group they're like oh my
God she's the most annoying one of all
of us you know here it seemed like they
were all kind of like equal level
friends and you couldn't really tell
what the Dynamics or intricacies of
their relationships were as much uh and
I I think that the actors did an amazing
job too cuz there's no real conflict
between them whereas like the first
movie there's a conflict between them
well there's a conflict between him and
Amaya but we also still like uh but it
kind of felt underd yeah yeah yeah
totally they were like we know we need a
conflict between them which is why she
won't go over there but what is that
conflict it's going to be very brief uh
still cringing over me in the first
minute of this being like why isn't she
speaking that was so fun they're like
like if there's anything they really set
up you were like what I don't know
sometimes you know how it just takes you
a minute when you're watching a movie to
like get into it and I just I was seeing
everything that was happening but it
just wasn't clicking for me Story of My
Life uh okay those were our thoughts
yeah overall I'd still give it like an
eight out of 10 yeah me too honestly I
think that this is a cool franchise is
this the second and last or is this the
second I think this is the last one they
made and I don't really know what the
hell I wouldn't order like what do you
pitch for a third one something Z
something uh pandemic related I feel
like this might have been it come on
Roxy your thing look at that look up
I'll look up for you when it came out
this wasn't pandemic related I mean this
this feels like it was on Skype so you
know it's not pandemic related you're
right that was Zoom wasn't it um when
did they could theoretically just do a
movie that takes place during the
pandemic yeah right that's what I'm
saying they're all on Zoom wearing masks
mhm when did
unfriended I'm going to say it took
place in
yeah maybe
2018 2018 really close because I
remember you reading
2016 yeah yeah unfriended three let's
see if there's going to be
come they did a oh they did they did a a
thing called what rhymes with Roxy
foxy no Moxy keep
going
foxy there's like barely any words that
run with Roxy there's like a few words
coxy
proxy
proxy Jesus I said the ones that come to
mind first
coxy you got like you got like three to
four words that would r with
you what about proxy
bro they did something called unfriend I
don't know what these are I don't think
there's are connected there's one called
unfriended proxy it's a short film that
they made in 2020 did they make it or
somebody made
it I don't know let me see who wrote
it no no I think these guys were trying
to rip off the franchise actually is
what I think we're looking at I just to
be 100% honest I would thrive in this
franchise all right yeah way to audition
yourself
yep cuz I would be like what Rob with
Roxy
socky all that impro for like going to
Fan
out okay we got to get out of here we do
um that's it yeah that's it man okay
that's it peace out
[Music]
Rel